reviews are pouring in for Dark Phoenix
the second cinematic attempt to adapt
the classic Marvel storyline of the same
name and they are for the most part not
good the flick is currently hovering
just above 20 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
what happened
Doug Phoenix focuses on a serious
problem faced by the x-men how to deal
with beloved team member Jean Cregg
when she is imbued with a mysterious
cosmic Phoenix force which overwhelms
her too disruptive results the storyline
was featured as a subplot in 2006 x-men
The Last Stand in case the sounds
strangely familiar the film is a
directorial debut of longtime x-men
franchise producer Simon Kinberg and
judging by the reviews it's easier to
see how the film's failure could be
chalked up to his inexperience with a
talented cast and a story that is a
stuff of legend in comics law kim berg
managed to turn in a picture that Rotten
Tomatoes critics consensus calls quote
deeply disappointing writing for York
dispatch Katie Walsh was particularly
urged by the performance of the film's
lead sophie Turner Walsh wrote Kimber
gas said to be a sledgehammer requiring
her to shout every emotional beat and
turn relentlessly hammering the themes
and messaging the critic also reserved
plenty of scorn for the flick script
what's truly amazing about Dark Phoenix
is watching the charismatic
award-winning star post cast flail about
in this poorly written nonsense cartoon
perhaps its worst offenses proving that
x-men apocalypse started in its
treatment of Oscar Isaac
despite the caliber and talent of the
actor lackluster writing directing and
editing can warp a performance into
something truly dreadful now that's
power that zone continues throughout the
reviews with many viewers lamenting how
curiously flat Dark Phoenix felt
despite its emotional high stakes story
william Viviani of the rap rhodes turner
tries to some success when fuse a
simplistic and irrational storyline with
some humanity but everyone else in sight
they're more interested in what craft
service made for lunch that day it's
just a disappointingly average superhero
flick with a familiar story
disinterested characters some cool
action sequences and a whole lot of
missed opportunities Business Insider's
review also took notice of the fact that
the cast looks kind of bored with the
entire enterprise so boring that review
stated even the characters who have been
around since x-men first class conk
things exciting jennifer lawrence's
mystique looks like to rather be
somewhere else of course not all
reviewers agreed with the consensus
although even the positive reviews took
care to point out the film's many flaws
Forbes Mark Hughes wrote that the movie
wasn't acceptable if not amazing end to
the series his review stated while Dark
Phoenix is not among the best x-men
movies it's not among the worst either
it is safely in the middle range of okay
flawed but with some things to praise
and overall managing to maintain the
status quo without improving it not
tanking it unfortunately
Dark Phoenix continued to decline in
quality to the back half of its second
act with choppy editing and a lot of why
would they do that or why wouldn't they
do this instead moments most observers
however were firmly in the consensus
camp and more than a few were downright
hostile in perhaps the most blistering
takedown leveled at the film Clint
Worthington of the spoiled Rhodes Dark
Phoenix as a film in mourning of its
characters its franchise even of its own
previously pristine state before the
laser reshoots turned into a
Frankenstein's monster of its former
self it's a franchise that sees its own
death coming at one point our heroes are
captured by military personnel who
literally have the letters MCU
emblazoned on their gear
and greets it with a resigned sigh for
that reason at least Doug Phoenix
carries a morbid fascination it's a good
point the movie could still leave fans
excited for the future if not exactly
for the reasons our filmmakers wanted
Marvel Studios parent company Disney
having recently acquired the film and
television are sets of Fox Studios is in
an excellent position to rehabilitate
these characters within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in the years to come
so despite this movie's lousy reception
maybe the future of the x-men isn't so
dark after all just because someone
stars
their way it touched me a lot check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and at the Bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]